[Música]
aquí comienza a ellos hoy de france24 el
consejo de ministros de perú aprobó el
20 de abril el proyecto de ley de
castración química contra violadores de
menores de edad adolescentes y mujeres
esto ha pedido del presidente pedro
castillo tras el caso de una niña de
tres años secuestrada y brutalmente
abusada en chiclayo esta no es la
primera vez que se discute la medida que
busca evitar la reincidencia pero que no
ataca los orígenes criminales de las
violencias machistas en 2018 el congreso
presionó para incluir el castigo pero la
viabilidad constitucional es
cuestionable pues las penas corporales
están prohibidas en el país y además las
violaciones no sólo implican penetración
con los genitales
analizaremos si esta propuesta del
gobierno de pedro castillo realmente
combate los crímenes contra las mujeres
y las niñas pero antes aquí está el
contexto el presidente peruano pedro
castillo propuso una ley de castración
química para los violadores estamos
planteando aplicar la castración química
como una de las medidas drásticas contra
los violadores de menores de edad
adolescentes y mujeres esta propuesta
será formalizada en los próximos días y
esperamos el respaldo del congreso y que
no le dé la espalda a un clamor popular
castillo dijo que esperaba el apoyo del
congreso tras conocerse que una niña de
tres años fue secuestrada y violada en
la localidad de chiclayo el 13 de abril
la policía local detuvo un hombre de 48
años acusado de crímenes atroces al
intervenir la policía logra
de tenerlo
el dueño del carro y él confiesa su
segundo piso
el nuevo caso ha dotado de una violencia
machista atronadora provocó
manifestaciones de rechazo en las calles
de lima grupos de ciudadanos pidieron
justicia para la pequeña repitiendo una
verdad obvia que no se respeta las niñas
no deben ser violadas
el gobierno no está
para la ciudadanía es inaceptable que el
gobierno no logre frenar las violencias
contra las mujeres ahora con la
propuesta de castillo queda en el aire
la sensación de populismo de un mandato
en crisis y que no va ataca la raíz de
los crímenes de género
la conversación sobre esta noticia es
con cinthia silva feminista y abogada
especializada en justicia de género y
directora de la organización de musgo
perú que defiende los derechos sexuales
y reproductivos de las mujeres cintia
gracias y la castración química ya es
legal en países como corea del sur
polonia también república checa y en
algunas partes de los eeuu sirve la
medida para combatir el abuso sexual
buenas buenas y cómo están
pues definitivamente desde las
instituciones desde colectivas
feministas de mujeres en perú
señalamos que no es efectiva no y no
apunta tampoco a la real con y
recuperación que las mujeres las niñas
con sus dos genes sufren entonces lo que
necesitamos es superar esta este
estereotipo en el que se basa esta
medida que es el de la irrefrenable
lidad sexual de los hombres no y más
bien atacar las raíces que tienen que
ver con que el problema no es el el
deseo sexual el libio sexual sino que se
utilice ésta esta característica humana
para imponer el poder masculino al
dominio masculino sobre las mujeres
sobre eso les quería hablar también es
cintia que se me fue hasta mi siguiente
pregunta porque pedro castillo vendió la
propuesta como una forma de aplicar mano
dura contra depravados y degenerados que
destruyen la vida de niños y jóvenes así
textualmente lo dijo pero el hombre
abusador cynthia fue un niño abusado
entonces ahí por eso le quería preguntar
dónde tenemos que actuar realmente
porque la importancia de reevaluar cómo
estamos criando las masculinidades
si efectivamente
la incluso las estéticas en el perú que
hablan de que el 95 por ciento de
víctimas de delitos sexuales son mujeres
y el 5 por ciento son hombres estos
hombres son niños
y evidentemente cuando vemos quienes son
los mayores agresores son adultos
hombres entonces si bien no en todos los
casos se presenta antecedentes de
violencia sexual en los agresores
sexuales pues a lo que a lo que vamos es
a una en una no patologización de la
sexualidad sino más bien a
atacar estos crímenes como lo que son
crímenes de poder crímenes en los que lo
que está detrás es la formación de una
masculinidad
dominante una oportunidad abusiva no que
y además lo que les hace pensar a los
niños como los forma es como personas
que no pueden controlarse que no pueden
gobernarse textualmente cuando esto pues
es totalmente falso la idea entonces es
insistir y
fortalecer políticas de igualdad de
género políticas también que están
vinculadas con la educación sexual
integral para formar desde niños niñas a
las personas en relaciones igualitarias
respetuosas no y conocimiento de sus
cuerpos para una para un futuro
relacionamiento en el ámbito de la
sexualidad sano e igualitario mire el
ministro de justicia- félix ero dijo que
esta medida iba a ir acompañada de
educación y también de temas de salud
mental pero el ministro el ministro de
salud jorge lópez no apoyó la medida y
tampoco lo hicieron los papás de la
víctima ni los colectivos feministas que
lamentaron que el gobierno no comprenda
cómo es que opera realmente la violencia
sexual cuál es el camino entonces para
sanar a esta niña y para protegernos a
todas estas políticas vienen desde casa
en qué términos debe darse esa educación
y esa prevención que tan vagamente se
menciona en las medidas contra estos
crímenes
y
lamentablemente el proyecto de ley que
está
está elaborado y se ha presentado ahora
va a presentar al congreso desde el
poder ejecutivo
no menciona ninguna medida relacionada
a la salud de las víctimas es decir no
tiene ninguna muestra de interés por la
recuperación de los impactos graves que
la violencia sexual tiene en las
víctimas se centra en la
en la medida de
castración química y de producción dice
de la libido sexual de los hombres
y con eso se centra entonces en una
patológica jon de la de la sexualidad no
desconociendo como les decía los
crímenes que esto se trata de pues
acción de
imposición de crímenes de poder en
contra de las mujeres y en todo caso a
lo que vamos es que no se trata de una
enfermedad de nada
tampoco de un hecho de que se ha
cometido con personas que tengan
perfiles asimilables a monstruos
lamentablemente en nuestro país las
condenas para llegar incluso a lo que
quisieran que es una castración química
pues son muy muy difíciles pues demoran
demasiado
demoran entre 8 y 10 años para los pasos
de
de niñas que son los casos que mas
sensibilizan seguramente no
y también hay muchos obstáculos que
implican una revictimización en las
agraviadas lo cual hace que ellas pues
abandonen los procesos no que son muchas
veces más dañinos para ellas entonces
los casos son muy difíciles de
concluir con condena y por lo tanto
tampoco es que estamos viendo que estas
condenas que desde ya en nuestro son
bastante graves actualmente en la cadena
perpetua la que la que se impone para
estos casos no se debería imponer para
estos pasos según el código penal pues
ni siquiera está realmente aplicada no
entonces lamentablemente hay mucho por
hacer todavía eso que usted nos dice no
solamente es la radiografía del perú
sino es la radiografía de américa
latina- en los casos de violencia sexual
y por eso quisiera preguntarle ya cuando
nos estamos acercando al cierre de este
programa porque nuestra tarea aquí es
visibilizar y concientizar qué pasa en
la psique de una mujer violada
que este crimen se compara con el
asesinato
el impacto de la violencia sexual en las
mujeres y las niñas es sumamente grave
lo dice ya una
experta en la materia marta rondón
psiquiatra que justamente en las niñas
este proceso evolutivo de construcción
de su personalidad se ve gravemente
afectado en el caso de las mujeres
adultas no es menos grave en la medida
que esta violencia sexual se suma a una
serie de experiencias que todas las
mujeres tenemos a lo largo de nuestras
vidas experiencias de violencia sexual
digamos de distintos niveles de gravedad
y no sólo ellos sino que para niñas y
mujeres existe un ambiente que nos
comunica una una
riesgo permanente en tanto en nuestras
casas como en la
públicos de una posibilidad de vivencia
de una viole un tipo de violencia sexual
entonces
hay graves afectaciones hay que atender
desde las que los servicios del estado
necesitamos que las políticas públicas
se fortalezcan para atender
efectivamente a estos impactos que la
violencia sexual y pues grava la a
nuestras vidas pero también para
prevenir esta esta violencia y esto
sostenemos que se debe hacer desde
políticas de prevención de la violencia
basada en género que sostengan no
solamente el sector salud sino también
al sector en ocasiones en ese sentido la
educación sexual integral también es una
respuesta que va a ser mucho más
efectiva desde el estado para no seguir
lamentando estos pasos bueno pues es
nuestra tarea de educar niños y niñas
para que no se conviertan en violadores
en gracias a usted por estar con
nosotros en ellas hoy ya nuestros
televidentes más programas en france24
punto come y nos vemos próximamente en
ellas hoy
[Música]